so it's nice to have the Sun is on very  nice got a second meeting this week  actually we have two marketing geniuses  that is Anka and a guy Mark who's  absolutely useless working that where to  go in London but exactly but no we we  meeting a client that has partnered with  us to build a strategy for it's a  greater business essentially so it's  going to be exciting and looking forward  to it oh that is first week done safe to  say I have been chucked in right the  deep end which if I'm honest I actually  prefer the exact same in recruitment and  yeah I just know that which was one of  the biggest reasons why I decided to  double down on this is that I'm gonna be  learning loads and  oh this week showed it so yeah exciting  exciting times ahead I know that I'm  gonna be failing getting challenged so  we will see how it goes